[Musique]
bonjour à tous je m'appelle angélique
cadet j'ai 25 ans je suis maman solo
animatrice socioculturel et aussi
autrice de plusieurs romans jeunesse
donc si je suis ici aujourd'hui parmi
vous c'est parce qu'il y a à peu près un
mois j'ai été contacté par TEDx
Saint-Denis women pour venir aborder la
thématique de cette année qui est
repensée donc moi je me suis imaginée
partager mon parcours de vie personnelle
à travers un voyage dans le temps
donc on va tous ensemble voyager dans le
temps ok vous êtes prêts vous inquiétez
pas ça va bien se passer détendez-vous
respirez
ok c'est parti
donc nous voici désormais en 2003
j'ai 6 ans j'ai fait mon entrée au CP et
je suis une enfant qui est vraiment
tétanisé par le monde qui l'entoure j'ai
peur de tout et de tout le monde mais à
côté de ça j'ai énormément de rêves je
rêve de découvrir le monde du rêve de
voler comme un oiseau dans le ciel je
rêve de voir la neige parce que moi j'ai
grandi sur une île et puis la neige
c'est vraiment waouh incroyable faire
des bonhommes de neige et tout vous vous
rendez compte et puis secrètement aussi
je rêve de devenir une super star donc
plein de fois je me suis imaginé monté
sur une scène face à un public et je
redis est-ce que vous êtes chaud et le
public aurait fait ouais
[Musique]
et maintenant comme on est tous ensemble
en 2023 avec la petite angélique je vous
propose qu'on réalise un rêve d'enfant
donc je vais dire est-ce que vous êtes
chaud vous allez faire ouais et tout ok
j'ai kiffé vous êtes prêts
1 2 3 est-ce que vous êtes chaud
[Applaudissements]
ils sont encore plus incroyable que
quand j'avais fait toutes les
répétitions
vous avez réalisé un rêve d'enfant donc
merci beaucoup bon maintenant qu'on a
franchi ce cap on peut avancer un petit
peu plus sur le temps OK
donc maintenant nous sommes en 2012 j'ai
14 ans et je suis en pleine crise
d'adolescence mais vraiment vous aurez
détesté l'ado que j'étais
je suis plus du tout terrifiée par le
monde qui m'entoure mais je suis très en
colère vraiment j'ai la haine contre
tout et tout le monde
mais il y a une raison derrière tout ça
c'est parce que à cette époque là ma
mère vient de rencontrer un seul type
qui est en train de nous détruire
totalement qui nous fait beaucoup de mal
et ma mère elle va sombrer dans une
dépression qui va même l'amener vers une
maladie mentale qui est la schizophrénie
donc moi j'ai 14 ans je comprends pas
forcément qu'est-ce qui se passe chez
moi ça devient très glauque je subis des
violences physiques des violences
psychologiques et puis ma mère elle
commence à changer de comportement et je
comprends pas vraiment et puis elle me
dit que c'est de ma faute donc je me
sens mal je me sens coupable je me sens
être une mauvaise fille et du coup ben
j'en parle pas parce que j'ai honte sauf
que deux jours en jours ben mon
quotidien il va se transformer en enfer
et je vais vraiment me sentir comme
prisonnière d'un truc qui me dépasse
puis j'apprends que je vais devenir
grande sœur et un jour je sors de
l'école je rentre chez moi et je
découvre genre un tout petit bébé toute
innocent comme ça que je prends dans mes
bras et je me sens instantanément
responsable de ma petite sœur du coup
donc j'arrive plus trop à suivre mes
cours à l'École etc parce que je fais
que de penser à ma petite sœur et je me
dis est-ce qu'elle est bien est-ce
qu'elle est en sécurité est-ce qu'il va
rien lui arriver de mal parce que chez
moi il se passe des trucs vraiment pas
top donc c'est comme ça que petit à
petit je commence mon décrochage
scolaire finalement je vais plus vouloir
aller à l'école je vais vouloir que
rester chez moi à protéger ma petite
sœur être sûr qu'elle va bien
ma petite heure c'est moi qui l'a appris
à marcher c'est moi qui l'a appris à
parler
j'ai essayé d'être le plus
bienveillant possible et d'être la
meilleure grande sœur possible pendant
un certain temps donc voilà un petit peu
à quoi ressemblait mon adolescence on va
avancer encore un petit peu dans le
temps
nous sommes en 2013 j'ai 16 ans et je
viens d'apprendre que je suis enceinte
que j'ai un tout petit bébé dans le
ventre et comme vous le savez moi
j'étais une adolescente vraiment rebelle
je l'ai testé tout le monde j'ai testé
mes profs et mes profils étaient testés
aussi il me dit mais qu'est-ce que tu
fais là tu es un élément perturbateur tu
ferais mieux d'arrêter l'école et donc
quand j'ai appris que j'étais enceinte
c'était la première excuse et pour leur
dire bah c'est bon j'arrête quoi donc
j'ai décidé d'arrêter l'école et j'ai dû
prendre la décision la plus difficile de
toute ma vie c'est celle de quitter la
maison dans laquelle j'ai grandi parce
que je savais que si je restais ici
j'allais finir par perdre mon bébé mais
en quittant la maison c'est aussi ça
veut dire aussi de d'abandonner ma
petite sœur et ça vraiment c'est la
décision qui m'a littéralement brisé le
coeur
donc j'ai passé une grande partie de ma
grossesse en étant SDF donc je dormais
sur des trottoirs dans la rue dans le
froid je dormais dans des vieilles
voitures abandonnées sur un parking et
parfois je dormais pas aussi parce que
le monde de la rue c'était super
effrayant mais pas plus effrayant que
chez moi donc je vous rappelle que c'est
quand même pour ça que je voulais rester
à la rue dans un sens et finalement il y
a eu quand même quelques âmes d'une
charitable on va dire qui m'ont hébergé
pendant un certain temps mais j'étais
quand même pas mal ballotté de droite à
gauche
arrivé à mes 7 mois de grossesse je me
suis dit c'est pas possible de continuer
comme ça je vais finir par littéralement
à coucher dans la rue et donc j'ai
décidé de
d'aller chercher de l'aide vers des
personnes qui auraient pu m'aider à
trouver des solutions etc faut savoir
que tout au début de ma grossesse
j'étais déjà partie vers les services
sociaux vers des personnes qui auraient
pu m'aider sauf qu'on m'a fermé toutes
les portes on m'a dit bah il y a plus de
place dans les foyers tes parents ils
veulent pas de toi et puis de toute
façon qui voudrait d'une ado ensemble
donc en gros par des bruits toi toute
seule et c'est ce que j'ai dû faire
sauf qu'arrivée à mes sept mois de
grossesse je commence à avoir des
contractions et là je me suis dit je
vais vraiment finir par accoucher à la
rue donc je suis repartie vers des
personnes pour réclamer de l'aide et
c'est là que j'ai eu enfin mon premier
appartement mon vrai chez moi et à
partir de là je me suis dit c'est bon je
peux tourner la page je peux entamer une
toute nouvelle vie et laisser tout se
passif douloureux derrière moi
voilà donc hop
2014 je deviens maman et j'apprends à
vivre mais genre avec un grand V
j'apprends ce que c'est que le bonheur
j'apprends à aimer et je suis une toute
nouvelle personne je décide vraiment de
me concentrer sur moi sur mon enfant et
j'essaie de me reconstruire forcément
c'était pas facile puisque moi j'étais
maman solo depuis le début là jusqu'en
2022 ça fait 8 ans que j'élève ma fille
toute seule et au début c'est vrai que
moi j'avais beaucoup de traumatismes et
j'avais aussi beaucoup tous ces bruits
du monde qui continuent à me hanter donc
ce sont des voix des paroles que j'ai
entendu à un certain moment dans ma vie
des choses comme tu n'y arriveras pas
[Musique]
tu finiras comme ta mère
tu aurais dû avorter
et donc tout ça c'est vrai que ça m'a
bloqué pendant un certain temps
tous les jours je me réveillais j'avais
des crises d'angoisse
tous les jours je me disais est-ce que
je peux le faire vraiment est-ce que
j'en serai capable et puis je me suis
dit finalement je suis forte tout ça ça
m'a permis aussi d'être plus forte plus
courageuse plus déterminé d'avoir plus
la rage moi aujourd'hui je vais être pas
la maman lambda je vais être la maman
super méga badass au dessus de toutes
les marrons et voilà je pense que j'y
arrive pas mal j'arrive bien à gérer et
tout
voilà et puis un jour je rencontre aussi
un garçon
un garçon qui me pose une question qui
peut sembler toute bête mais cette
question là elle a vraiment permis
d'avoir un déclic dans ma vie et c'était
c'est quoi ton rêve et donc je vous
avoue que quand il m'a posé cette
question là j'avais 17 ans je n'ai
d'être maman je t'ai encore un peu dans
la galère
et je lui dis mais je vais rien dire en
fait j'ai eu un blanc et donc et là je
l'ai pris conscience quand même que
j'avais pas de rêve et vu sa réaction a
commencé à t'as pas de rêve t'as pas
d'ambition il y a rien qui te fait
vibrer enfin tu es jeune c'est pas
normal et tout et là je me suis dit ah
ouais peut-être qu'un problème
et c'est vrai que j'avais oublié tous
mes rêves même les rêves de cette petite
angélique là et en fait ce qui s'est
passé c'est qu'à l'adolescence c'était
un passage tellement dur pour moi
j'étais tellement dans un système de
survie où tous les jours déjà je me
disais mais si je vis déjà encore
jusqu'à demain bah c'est incroyable
parce que moi j'étais vraiment dans le
fond du gouffre je me disais mais
j'aurais jamais de maison jamais de
voiture jamais de métier enfin déjà
enfin c'est tellement dur je suis
tellement dans la galère et tout pour
moi en fait j'avais juste tiré un trait
sur mon affaire et je me suis dit j'y
arriverai jamais
sauf que bah quand il m'a reposé cette
question finalement j'avais déjà passé
un certain câble dans ma vie et je me
suis dit bah ouais peut-être que
maintenant j'ai droit j'ai le droit de
rêver enfin tout simplement
donc c'est ce garçon c'est comme s'il
m'avait pris par là ma main elle m'avait
dit regarde tu vois là-bas il y a une
place pour toi dans ce monde là et cette
place il y a droite à droite d'aller la
prendre parce qu'elle t'appartient et tu
le mérites donc voilà il m'a pris la
main on allait sur le petit chemin de la
vie il m'a poussé à trouver une place de
garde pour enfin en crèche pour ma fille
m'a poussé vraiment à me réinsérer dans
le monde à me insérer dans une vie
active et professionnelle et puis il m'a
même traîné jusqu'à une auto-école pour
moi c'est reconnu c'était vraiment un
coach de la vie et puis finalement lui
il avait aussi ses propres rêves donc il
est allé il m'a lâché la main il allait
vivre ses rêves pour suivre sa vie moi
j'ai poursuivi mon chemin sauf que
maintenant j'avais une détermination
je me suis dit c'est bon j'ai assez
galéré j'ai assez souffert et moi tout
ce que je veux c'est être heureuse mais
être heureuse sur tous les plans être
sur le poulet en professionnel
personnel enfin voilà dans ma vie
sociale etc donc je me suis beaucoup
cherché j'ai fait beaucoup de formations
au début j'ai eu peur je me suis dit
mais il y a rien qui m'attire genre je
veux pas devenir vendeuse je veux pas
devenir architecte je vais pas venir si
ça ça je sais pas du tout pourquoi
est-ce que je suis là et j'ai continué à
chercher à chercher et finalement j'ai
trouvé le domaine de l'animation dans
lequel je m'épanouis énormément
j'adore proposer des projets faire des
ateliers créatifs partager ma créativité
tout ça mon enthousiasme avec plein de
public et j'ai trouvé aussi l'écriture
donc à travers l'écriture j'ai pu aussi
va déposer toute cette souffrance cette
colère ses peurs enfin tout se passif
etc vraiment m'exprimer à travers des
histoires et donc voilà dernier petit
voyage pour revenir en 2022
donc 2022 me voici la toute nouvelle
mise à jour de angélique cadet et à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui donc je suis
animatrice socioculturel j'adore ce que
je suis je suis je kiffe mon travail
j'écris des livres moi la angélique qui
avait 16 ans qui a arrêté l'école celle
à qui on disait tu n'y arriveras pas
ouais bah j'y suis arrivé j'écris des
livres qui sont publiés distribués dans
tous les librairies de France
je voyage je découvre le monde et je
réalise les rêves de la petite angélique
donc je suis allée en Europe je suis
allée en Angleterre je suis allée en
Amérique je suis allé rencontrer mes
personnages de dessins animés préférés
dans des parcs d'attractions j'ai volé
dans le ciel et j'ai vu la neige cette
année j'ai vu la neige et vraiment et ça
lui rigoler mais moi j'ai pleuré moi
j'ai pleuré comme un enfant genre
tu fais un bonhomme de neige et tout
j'ai kiffé ok
mais pour moi ça me semblait impossible
enfin ça fait rire mais moi ça me
semblait tellement impossible de là où
je viens et puis voilà j'ai enfin voilà
je m'épanouis de jour en jour j'ai même
de nouveaux rêves moi mon nouveau rêve
ce serait que les histoires que j'écris
dans mes livres deviennent une grande
série distribue sur une grande
plateforme de streaming à
l'international
et ça fait rire mais mon rêve je le
prends très au sérieux ok c'est mon rêve
et donc moi bah aujourd'hui j'ai une
seule question à vous poser c'est et toi
c'est quoi ton rêve
prenez cette question vraiment au
sérieux ok prenez un moment pour penser
ou repenser la place que vous méritez
vraiment dans ce monde là c'est quoi
votre rêve c'est quoi le job qui vous
fait vibrer c'est quoi cette passion que
vous exercez en secret mais que vous
avez pas vraiment dévoilé ça au monde
entier c'est quoi ce voyage que vous
vous êtes imaginez fait et faire plein
de fois mais que vous avez jamais fait
parce que vous vous dites ah j'ai pas le
temps j'ai pas assez d'argent je parle
pas bien anglais enlever toutes ces
barrières ça ça c'est des ça c'est des
faux prétextes juste pour pas réaliser
votre rêve imaginez que là tout de suite
maintenant vous ayez tous les moyens
financiers humains zéro barrière pour
réaliser le rêve tout de suite
maintenant essayez de
ressentir l'effet que ça pourrait vous
procurer
vous ressentez le truc ou pas
est-ce que vous êtes dans l'exercice ou
pas mais vraiment essayer de prendre un
temps de le faire et c'est vraiment vous
dire purée ça pourrait être vraiment
incroyable et j'en vous sentez bien vous
sentez heureux et tout et déjà si vous
arrivez faire à faire cette petite
exercice déjà vous aurez franchi un
grand pas et moi ce que je vous invite à
faire c'est de faire ce petit exercice
tous les jours pourquoi parce que moi
déjà je le fais il se passe des trucs de
dingue dans ma vie mais de ouf genre moi
il y a un mois histoire vraie j'étais
sur Hollywood Boulevard
on m'a confondu avec une actrice et sur
un malentendu j'ai failli tourner dans
un film à Hollywood de ouf
sauf que moi il y a un mois ben j'avais
pas forcément les moyens financiers d'y
aller je parlais pas anglais et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que vous avez jamais
vouloir dans le film mais moi je sais
que j'étais avec les mêmes acteurs qui
sont passés là-dedans mais voilà juste
pour un petit souci d'anglais mais
qu'est-ce que c'était kiffant quoi quand
même de super de parler avec les gens et
tout et du coup voilà c'est pas ces
opportunités là je les ai eus
mais pas forcément parce que j'avais
l'argent parce que j'avais ceci cela ok
je les ai eu parce que vraiment je pense
c'est un truc magique tu les as parce
que à un moment donné tu as tellement
cru en toi tu as tellement cru enterré
tu as tellement dégagé une énergie tu as
tellement parlé de tes rêves que voilà
il y a un jour il y a quelqu'un qui
débarque et qui dit tiens hop des
billets vas-y vas-y c'est ton rêve et
c'est vrai ben c'est aussi simple que ça
et ça ces opportunités là c'est pas
juste pour ranger les cadets c'est pas
juste pour certaines personnes je pense
que c'est accessible à tout le monde
faut juste savoir la bonne énergie la
bonne intention et vraiment se prendre
au sérieux et prendre ses rêves au
sérieux donc voilà c'est tout ce que
j'avais à vous dire aujourd'hui donc
merci beaucoup